thanks for joining us America glad
you're here brian is on twitter you can
follow me there at Dave Ramsey this is
Dave on the show you said that the stock
market is averaged around 12% a year can
you tell me where you got that number
from sure sp500 that standard pour 500
is probably the most accurate measure of
the stock market the Dow Jones
Industrial Average is only a handful of
stocks the S&P 500 is an index that is
the top 500 companies traded on the New
York Stock Exchange that is what we call
the stock market there are several
markets but that's what people could
refer to when they say the stock market
and it's a market where stocks are
exchanged the new york stock exchange
where we buy and sell anyway the top 500
companies on there in terms of size if
you look at the average of the standard
and poor and the estimates of what it
would have been had at those particular
companies been in existence since the
stock market's inception
you'll see an eleven and a half to a 12
percent rate of return average annual
now that's average annual there's
different ways to calculate the math on
it but that's the number that we use in
the number that we're quoting all the
time we're talking about 12% and people
get all torqued out and upset about this
stuff but that's that's what it's done
and I own several mutual funds that have
averaged well over 12% in the scope of
their lifetime and many of them are very
very old 50 or 60 or 70 years old and
you can find them that do that now that
is not 12% compounded there is a
difference and people criticize me for
not you know laying out that difference
that's fine you can criticize me all you
want but what we imitate what we found
we just found a recent piece of research
and this is this is what we based
everything we're doing on is this
mentality the recent piece of research
said that the number one reason that
people don't have money at retirement is
not because of their poor rate of return
it's because they never invest let me
tell you what you
rate of return is the quality of your
assets on money you never invest zero
zero the number one problem in
retirement readiness in America today
the number one reason 401k plans are
failing at your workplace management
team is not because you don't offer good
mutual fund options in the 401k it's
because people don't put any freakin
money in the funds and then you have a
zero percent rate of return and you can
discuss real rate of return post
inflation you can discuss all these
freaking mathematical theories that you
some of you financial nerds just sit
around and crunch your numbers all the
time and you do nothing to help people
and what we do is we get people to
actually invest are they going to get
12% no they might get 14 are they going
to get 14 no they might get 18 last year
it wouldn't been unusual to get 18 in
that year that is do i project that as
an average annual going forward no I
don't but do I believe this crap that
you people put out there the markets
only going to have rich six percent when
it's averaged almost double that because
all you do is sit and beat your gums
some of you in the financial world and
run your freakin mouth and you don't do
anything except talk people into being
negative about this stuff because you're
such nerds and you get caught up in the
think tank aspects of the business
instead of understanding there are human
beings on the other side of this that
get a 0% rate of return 100% of the time
when they don't invest and that's the
number one reason people's retirement
program is failing is they don't put any
freaking money in it it's not because
they put it into a mutual fund that made
eleven point two five instead of eleven
point seven five ying ying ying ying
ying ying is shut up seriously you're
the problem with the business you got
all caught up in your math class the
senior level of college and you never
got out
then you started studying for your CFP
and your certified financial planner
which means one of two things if you
have a CFP it means one of two things it
means you are a certified financial
planner and you do a great job because
you understand that people that human
beings are on the other side of this
transaction and you actually think about
what actually gets people to invest and
you caused them to invest or CFP stands
for certified financial pharisee where
you get caught up in all you can do is
just deal in theory all the time you're
like a freakin college professor has
never done anything in life now college
professors don't have to be that kind of
college professor though they can
there's good ones and there's bad ones
there's some of them that are an example
of why tenure shouldn't exist and we've
all had those and we all had that
college professor that changed our life
too because they were awesome when
they're both out there and the same is
true in the financial world so Brian
built into your question is where can
you get twelve percent
well you look for good growth stock
mutual funds but the point is not 12
percent versus twelve and a half or
thirteen and a half or eleven and a half
the point is invest some freaking money
and don't get caught up in the minor
details of somebody's mathematical
analysis of stupidity and theory because
100% of the people projecting future
returns have no clue what they're going
to be except based on what they did in
the past but you know what the industry
has to say according to sit the
Securities Exchange Commission past past
performance is no guarantee of future
returns have you heard that a thousand
times it's no guarantee but it's the
number one forecasting method of
anything in business past performance of
my publishing department inside my
company is no guarantee of future
performance no but it does give us some
trendlines by which we can do reasonable
forecasting those of us that have half a
brain and run a business and so when
you're looking at a mutual fund and it
has a seventy year track record of 12.2%
is it a guarantee your future returns no
but it's a guarantee you're going to get
more there than you would have gotten on
your certificate of depression at 1% or
0.8 percent or 0.75 percent not even a
full percentage rate so in other words
that mutual fund that made 20 something
last year and has averaged 12 over 50 60
70 years it's got to do 10 times worse
than it's ever done in its history to
get down to your stupid CD that's pretty
bad it's got to underperform by 90
percent or 95 percent to get down to
where your CD is what it's done averaged
over 50 years now past performance is
not a guarantee of future returns we
know that anybody's got walking around
since when you bought that house you
didn't get a guarantee that the house
was going to go up in value but did you
kind of make an assumption based on the
fact that houses in that neighborhood
have gone up for the past 10 years that
is probably a good neighborhood to buy
in sure you did
simple forecasting technique and any
idiot that's got walking around sense
can do that except people in the
financial world some of them and so
that's what you've got to get to Brian I
don't know if that was a
passive-aggressive question you were
asking and you're taking a stab at me
I'm a little bit sensitive a little bit
raw because I've been worn out by these
financial morons out there running
around I'm sick of them but or if it was
an honest question either way you're
getting the same answer the same answer
is yes those returns are possible but
that's not the point
so yes I'm right but that's not the
point the point is you get a zero
percent rate of return 100 percent of
the time that you invest no money
because you stood on the sidelines and
discuss the freaking theory you're like
somebody who sits in plans and plans and
plans and plans and plans and plans and
plans and plans and plans and plans and
never leaves home you planned your trip
to Europe for 42 years and you never see
Europe before you die well get your butt
on a plane what's your problem
100% of time you will miss the shot that
you don't take Michael Jordan 100 I
missed 100 percent of the shots I didn't
take take your shot don't get caught up
in the analysis of am i at the top of
the jump that I have the Arkwright is it
going to be all net release the freaking
ball invest invest invest and don't let
somebody who lives their life and theory
talk you out of it this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you